- We going to either, we going
to either succeed or die tryin'.
It is what it is.
You can't control like
where your gifts come from.
You can only do somethin' about 'em.
You can't completely go off numbers to try
to sell something creative.
You have to come up with other
creative ways to sell it.
It isn't about what I
have, it's me knowing
my weaknesses and what I don't have.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
It's Evan, my one word
is, believe, and I believe
in people more than they
believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So, to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn
from singer and song writer, The Dream,
and my take on his top
10 rules of success.
Rule number five is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
down in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can be inspired
by it, as well and if you leave it
within the first couple of hours
of this video going
live, you have a chance
to win one of two daily prizes.
(upbeat music)
- I took everything that I
learned from a ethics standpoint
that my grandfather taught
me and put it into that.
Sayin' if you pound, pound
it as hard at whatever thing
in the same direction, if you
keep hitting it, at a certain
point it's going to
break and it'll open up.
So, that's what I did.
Like, it was like, okay, cool,
this is what I'm going to do.
I'm going to focus on this thing.
We going to either succeed or die tryin'.
It is what it is.
I completely seen all the stars
growing up as human beings
and I think that was the first thing.
As, and the first person that I made human
to me was Michael Jackson.
If I would have ever seen
him I knew in my heart
that I would treat him like a
person that has these talents.
You can't control like,
where your gifts come from,
you can only do somethin'
about 'em or you know,
go through life and try to
make sure that you leave
an impression on this world with what you
have on the inside.
So, whoever was singing
or writing I felt like
I wanted to be amongst them.
I didn't want to look up or
appear to them like I wanted
to be exactly in line with
those people and I still
see things that same way today.
I just developed this sense
of not wanting to have to lean
on somebody to get my job done.
So, eventually being around
like all these great producers,
like starting of course with
Tricky's brother, Laney,
who actually signed me to
my first publishing contract
after I wrote this record
called, Everything, for B2K.
I just picked up the drum
machine, start watching
their patterns, like I
understood how to make a record.
I knew what a hook was.
I knew what a B Section
was, and you just musically
tryin' to understand those same things.
And I grew up in the '80's
where all those melodic records,
you know, happened.
So, for me it was like, I
can hear it like a juke box
in my head, I just needed to get it out.
So but, finding that
you have good producers
that know how to, it could be the smallest
thing like a kick.
Like, Timberland has this
way of how he makes his kicks
and his snares like, and they're
on this little slide beat,
but you have to know what
you doin' when you hear it.
And so, all these things I get
to get in and listen to them
and pick it up, and still
now, like I'll listen
to somethin' and say, oh,
okay, that's how you doin' it.
And even new producers,
like, so along the way
I just picked up that drum
machine and that keyboard
and said, okay, I need to
know how to make a song 100%,
period, without using,
yeah, without needing anyone
if it come to that.
- Just because at the
moment if you want to create
and you call somebody and
they can't do it that day,
you don't want to get
frustrated and not be able
to do it yourself.
- Yeah, so I learned how to do everything.
It was the beat, it was writin' the song
and recording and engineering myself.
Oh wow, nobody ever brings that up.
Yes, I remember writin' that
song and they were sayin'
she was finished.
I was in Vegas working on
I think, Love versus Money,
at the time and they were
sayin' that she was finished
on her album and I said, not
if you write a great song
she not, you know.
And so, we wrote the song.
I remember goin' back to
Atlanta and Trick called me
and he was like, you know,
Celine is taking one song
off and she puttin' this
song on, she loves it.
I was like, alright well,
you know, get it poppin',
and then I think the
conversation led into,
I think she had tried
to cut the vocal like
a couple of times in her
way and she was being
vocal produced by somebody
and she just scrapped
everything and said, no, I
want to sing it how he sang it
with that type of vibe, you know.
And, that was the biggest
thing coming from Celine,
'cause you're like, who could tell anybody
how to sing something with
a voice like how she have.
But, the fact she recognized
vibe was a whole different
idea and I try to teach
people that all the time
and they don't really get
it, 'cause most of the time
they think it's about
singing, and it's like no,
it's about a feeling, you know.
I get to be the creative
person that sits in that room,
like, but with some type
of rational idea and not
just straight art, 'cause I
understand even by running
a business as a song writer,
people have to make money.
I get that, you know.
What I try to apply to it
though, is you can't completely
go off numbers to try to
sell something creative.
You have to come up with other
creative ways to sell it.
I was working at some collection agency.
I was really bad at it,
I was really bad at it.
- Sally Mae, hope it
wasn't Sally Mae, man.
- No, that's too good,
it was worse than that.
That's too good.
I remember just calling,
they say, I don't have it.
I'm like, alright, cool.
- You a G for that, man, ain't my money.
- It was really bad.
And, I had just started playing golf
at that particular time.
I stopped by the golf course
at like 7:30 in the morning
and I got on the first tee
at this golf course called,
Legacy, and I sat there
and I called into my job
and I quit, because I kind
of figured that if I didn't
put 100% into music
really, I was never going
to actually be great enough to stay in.
And so, I quit my job that
day not knowing how I was
going to pay rent the next
month and at that time
I didn't have a publishing deal.
And, that song is actually
what got me a publishing deal.
- Awesome, man.
So, you believed in yourself.
- Like I said, you got to be crazy enough
to believe in yourself.
- If it was on, up and
comin' artist right now,
what advice would you give 'em?
A serious up and comin' artist
- Oh, well, I would, pray
if you're with a label
you should probably
just pray that somebody
believes in you, like that one person
versus havin' a whole staff, making sure
you're being yourself
and eventually you know,
overall, just overcoming
the fears of not succeeding
in the eyes of what the public idea
and perception of succeeding is.
Be yourself at all times.
Never sell your soul to any machine.
Okay, if I become a artist
then, I'm going to stay at it
because I'm going to
always be singing my own.
It isn't about what I
have, it's me knowing
my weaknesses and what I don't have.
You can't trick me into what I am good at.
Nobody going to write
anything on a blog that's
going to say, Dream sucks at this.
Yeah, give your life like, that's not.
If you see me on the basketball court
then probably my fadeaway ain't there.
We can say, he can't play basketball.
You're right.
He can't write music, you've lost yo mind.
I can do anything.
I broke myself as a
artist at the age of 29.
If that isn't already
hard enough, you know,
to do what I've done in a
10 year period in this span,
to even be blessed
enough to be sitting here
in front of you guys talking about this.
I could wrap it up and
say, oh, cool, goals done
and just moving one, but
it's too many other things.
You know, once you movin' from
one thing it's all art to me.
It's all in a bowl like,
it's just on a plate.
There's the Ice Cube I
needed to chase down.
There's a Dr. Dre I need to chase down.
It's moved on from Lionel
and Diane to now, it's other
people that I see and say,
oh, they used that same brain
to get those things and I
can use my brain and actually
get to the same things that you have.
So it's just a everlasting
idea to keep pushing,
you know, myself.
This music thing is like
water, like it's not, my songs
are going to be my songs regardless.
People get hot and cold and wander off,
but you'll be back and when it's time
for you to get married or fall
in love again, I'll be here.
But, this idea of what
to do or what to do next
is what I've been doin' all along.
Like, these are just steps.
You know, I was already
preparing to be able to retire
at a very early age and not
meaning retire, you never
see me again, but oh, cool,
I can put my up and now
I can do whatever the
want to do, you know.
But, still use myself
and the things that I see
and the movies I want
to write and direct and
bring them to the world
'cause there is nobody has any
real idea what's in my
mind and heart sitting
on this stage, you just
know what I've done.
And, when I didn't have that stuff before,
you didn't know I could do
that, so we have no idea
what I can actually do.
We've seen great people come from nothing,
so if you have something
that means that you should go
to even higher levels of
achieving what your goals
and your dreams are.
I speak for all of us.
We have no excuses.
We will go on to be
exactly who we want to be
in pursuit of the American dream.
In the summer of 1992 my mother
was diagnosed with cancer.
Didn't know at the time how
serious it was, but that summer
was already a big transition
for me because they were
closing my high school
down, which was West Fulton,
so couldn't really get no worse.
I never thought that I would lose my mom
at the end of this year.
- After his mother passed
away his grandfather
kept him and raised him.
He provided him with most
everything he would ask for.
I remember his grandfather
bought him a set of drums
and he would be back in
his room playin' the drums
learnin' about music.
- Who I am as a father, I
take my responsibilities
as a father very, very heavy.
I try to do the best that
I can with what I have.
I try to make sure that I
can provide a better way
and provide more choices
and options for my children
that are going to come behind me.
You know, life is from
generation to generation,
building on choices.
(children making noise)
What loading means is that it's putting
it all inside your computer.
So, you have to wait til it get finished.
You see that little blue?
When that blue gets all the way to here
that means it's finished.
- That's like on the TV.
- Yeah, exactly.
If I had 10 choices and
10 directions I could go,
then my children should
have 100 and their children
should have 1000, that's
basically what it is.
Me, knowing that the sacrifices
I had to make you know,
with my grandfather working
all day and my mother
working, in no way deters
me, how to be a great father
in anyone's book is set in
stone or black and white.
There is no real way to do it.
There are only your
gifts, your opportunities
and your choices to do
the best that you can.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
you guys asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in a future Top 10,
please check out the link
down in the description below
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Bini Alex,
Bini, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and that
awesome message that you
had to share.
I'm so glad it's havin'
an impact on your life
and thank you for sharin' it and puttin'
it on Twitter, too.
I really, really appreciate the support.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- By the time we get to about
2007, imagine that you have
more control of your vision.
It's really shinin'
through now with a record
called, I'm Brother.
- Wow, yeah, that record
was done in a act of,
I would like to imagine
Mohammad Ali on the ropes
and just takin' it, just
takin' the pounding.
Life was, I was out of my publishing deal.
You don't know when
the stars are aligning,
it just depends on how, how much you can
keep your head up through it.
There could be aligning
and you now know it
which is most of the time.
I was checkin' pockets and stuff for like,
maybe I left a extra 20 over here to put
some gas in this.
- Did you still have the
Cadillac with leather seats?
- I had a Jaguar at the time.
Don't say, ahh, they tried to
repossess it like nine times.
I hid that good.
Every time, park down the
street and walk to yo apartment,
cover this up with some leaves.
And, it was just a weird
space to say, write a hit.
You know what a hit sounds like.
You know what songs you
like from other people.
Like, if you went to
make a playlist, you knew
what the a hit was and you
know you know how to make it,
so just write a hit.
So, I just told myself
that that day and literally
we're moving stuff around
in the studio, Koo Korell
who now's like side by side
with Rihanna and records
a lot of her stuff for her
now, finds a, finds this loop,
this kick loop.
Trick starts to play this
chord and I kind of walk in
at that same moment and I hear
it, and I heard about maybe
eight bars of what, what trick was doing
and I said, man, turn the mic on.
They was like, we not ready,
we just started movin'
this around, we got to plug
it up, we got to get it right.
Okay, cool, turn the mic on.
Turned the mic on.
I mean, we had to go back
and change four words,
but I sung it from the top to the end
exactly as is how you hear
the song today, right now.